this is the colored arasari a toucan  native to the tropical rainforests in  central and south america their bodies  are a gorgeous rainbow of colours with  bright plumage and large colourful bills  their bills are the most distinct  feature the upper part has a sawtooth  pattern helping them reach food on  branches they can't land on  collard rsaris reach just over a foot  long and weigh up to 10 ounces  most of that size comes from their bills  that take up over a quarter of its  entire body  they mainly eat fruit but occasionally  feed on small insects while they are  found in abundance throughout their  range their population has been  decreasing due to a combination of  deforestation and hunting for the pet  trade  this is the colored arrasari  you